DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
So today, the problem
I'd like to work with you
is about taking
partial derivatives
in the presence of constraints.
So this is a pretty
subtle business.
So take your time when
you work these problems.
So what we have is we
have this function w,
and it's a function of four
variables: x, y, z, and t.
OK?
But it's not really a function
of these four variables
because we have a constraint.
So we want to
study how w changes
as we vary the parameters,
except that we have imposed
this constraint here.
So that really we kind of
only have three variables,
because we have four
variables and one constraint.
So that's what partial
derivatives with constraints
help us do.
So let's explain
first the notation.
OK?
So it says partial w
partial z, and then we
have the subscripts x and y.
So what's important
about this notation
is not what you see as
much as what you don't see.
What you don't see
is the variable t.
OK?
So what this notation
means is, as always,
the denominator in our
derivative expression--
partial z here-- that means
that we want to vary z.
And we want to see how
w changes as we vary z.
And the x and y here mean that
we want to keep x and y fixed.
So if we didn't
have a constraint,
this x and y here
would be superfluous.
Because by partial
derivative, we always
mean to keep the other
unlisted variables unchanged.
However, the fact that
t is missing here,
it means that-- so if you
think about it-- if we vary z,
and we keep x and y fixed,
then t also is varying.
Right?
Because we have this
constraint here.
And so it wouldn't
make sense for me
to ask you to compute the
partial derivative of w
in z varying x, y, and t
because-- excuse me-- keeping
x, y, and t fixed,
because then there
would be no room for z to vary.
OK?
So this notation means that z
is going to be allowed to vary,
but it's going to vary
in a way that we're just
going to ignore.
So you will see how this
works out in the problem.
So what we're
really interested in
is making sure that x and y
stay fixed and that z varies.
And then we're going to need
to-- when we do some algebra,
we're going to need to
get rid of any mention
of the variable t.
OK.
So the first way that we're
going to work this out
is using total differentials.
And I like to use
total differentials
when I'm on new ground
because-- they're not
the most computationally
effective,
because they involve computing
all the derivatives that we
might possibly need in sight.
So they're not the most
efficient computationally.
But if you go ahead and compute
the total differentials,
then all the other
computations that you have
to do are just substitution.
So it really just
becomes linear algebra,
and that's what I like about it.
In part b, we'll see a shortcut
using implicit differentiation
and the chain rule.
And this is going to
be a little bit tricky.
So we have these
two equations, we
need to turn them both into
differential equations.
And so we'll do that
using a combination
of implicit differentiation
and the chain rule.
So I'll let you pause
the video and get
started on these problems.
And you can check back and
we'll work it out together.
OK, welcome back.
So let's start by doing a,
let's start with problem a.
So we have total differentials
is the suggested way
to attack this.
So why don't we
just start computing
the total differentials
that we know.
So we have two equations.
w in relation to the other
variables and the constraint
equation.
And what we first
want to do is just
take the total differential
of both of those equations
to get started.
So we can take the first one
and it tells us that dw is equal
to-- OK, so we have 3 x
squared y dx, plus x cubed dy,
minus 2z*t dz,
minus z squared dt.
OK.
Now right away, we can
simplify this equation.
So this is the
total differential,
but we have to remember
that in the setting we're
interested in, x and
y are held fixed.
And so holding x and y fixed
means that the differentials dx
and dy are both set to 0.
So that lets us rewrite this
first differential equation is
just dw equals minus 2z*t
dz minus z squared dt.
So that's our first
equation that we get.
Let me just check with
my notes to make sure.
That's right.
OK.
And so now, we have
the constraint equation
from the original
statement of the problem.
And we need to take
its differential.
So on the one hand,
we get x dy plus y dx.
That's the total differential
of the left-hand side.
And then on the right-hand
side, we have t dz plus z dt.
OK?
And now we notice that now the
left-hand side of this equation
is just 0 for the same reason.
dy and dx are being held fixed.
So the relation that
we end up getting
is we get that dt is equal
to minus t over z dz by just
doing straightforward algebra.
OK.
So, with that in
hand now, we can-- so
remember I mentioned
in the beginning
that our goal was-- so
from the very beginning,
we knew that if we varied z,
because of our constraint,
we're going to be
forced to be varying t.
And that's exactly what this
equation says, doesn't it?
We got this by just taking the
differential of the constraint.
And it says if you
vary z, you have
to vary t in an
appropriate way, and that's
what this coefficient tells us.
So what we're
really interested in
is how does w vary
in terms of z here.
And so we want to get
rid of this dt here.
And in fact, we can by
using the constraint.
So combining this equation
with this equation,
we get that dw here
is equal to-- OK,
so we have minus 2z*t dz.
And then we have minus-- OK--
z squared times another minus
times t over z, so this
all becomes a plus z*t dz.
So all I did is I plugged in
for dt using our formula here.
And so this altogether is
equal to just minus z*t dz.
And that tells us that the
partial derivative that we're
after is just this
coefficient, right?
The partial derivative
is just defined
to be the coefficient
of the differential
once you work everything out.
And so this is minus z*t.
OK, so that's a.
So now let's see if we can
use some tricks to make
the computation a bit shorter.
So the tricks that
we're going to use
are implicit differentiation
and the chain rule.
So at the end of the
day-- excuse me--
we're interested in
partial w partial z.
And what we're going to
do is use the chain rule
to just take a straightforward
partial derivative
of our original expression.
So remember, w was x
cubed y minus z t squared.
And so let's just take
a partial derivative
of that in the z-direction.
So the partial derivative in
the z-direction of x cubed y
is just 0.
So that will go away.
And so we only have minus--
we have a 2z*t component.
That's just because the partial
derivative of z squared is 2z.
And then we have another term
which is minus z squared,
and now we need to take
the partial derivative of t
in the z-direction.
So, you know, often times when
we take partial derivatives
of one variable in
terms of the other,
it's common to think that
the partial derivative of one
variable in terms of
the other is just 0.
Because usually our
variables are independent.
They don't vary in
terms of one another.
But this is exactly
a situation where
t does vary depending on z,
and so we had to include that
into our notation.
OK.
So now this is
almost what we want,
except we have this
mystery component here.
And of course,
there's only one way
we can solve this mystery, which
is the same way we solved it
in part a.
We have to use the constraint.
So let's take partial z of
our constraint equation.
And remember, our constraint
equation was x*y equals z*t.
OK.
So if we take the partial
derivative of this equation--
so if I take the partial
derivative of x and y
in terms of z, then I do
get 0, because x and y are
genuinely independent from z.
It's only t that depends on z.
So on this side we get 0.
Now, on the other side I just
need to use the product rule.
So I get t, plus z
partial t partial z.
OK?
So we can rewrite this as saying
that partial t partial z is
minus t over z.
OK?
Now, you might notice that,
you know, this is formally
very similar to what we did
in part a, and of course,
that's no surprise.
When we are manipulating
using implicit differentiation
and the chain rule,
it's just a compact way
of doing what we were doing
with the total differentials.
I mean, to me, the chain
rule is a computation
which you could prove by
doing the corresponding thing
with total differentials.
And so we get this same
coefficient negative t over z,
which you recall that
we got in part a.
OK.
So now we have, once again
we have this, two equations,
and we just can do substitution.
So we get that partial w partial
z is equal to minus 2z*t.
And now again, we get
minus another minus,
and z here cancels the z
squared, so we get plus z*t.
And so we get minus z*t.
OK, and finally, if we
remember our assumptions,
our assumptions were that x
and y were independent of z.
That was our notation.
And we use that assumption
at this step right here.
So in fact, we don't just have
the partial derivative of w
with respect to z.
We need to specify that
we held x and y fixed.
OK.
So just to review
again, if we look now
at what we did in part b, you
know, the meat of the argument
was the exact same as
what we did in part a.
The meat of the
argument was right here.
We took some derivative and
then this was an unknown.
The definition of
w doesn't know how
t and z depend on one another.
That you can only find by
looking at the constraint.
And so we just went
through the problem
and we took derivatives
of the constraint,
and that gave us an equation
that we were looking for.
Now if we go back now
to part a over here.
So as you can see, there's a lot
more work involved in part a.
On the other hand, to me it
was more straightforward.
We just had to compute
the total differentials
and then do some linear
algebra with cancellations.
And somehow, when you
do total differentials,
you just compute everything
that could possibly come up,
and then you just
substitute it in.
And indeed, we got
the same answer:
partial w partial z
as being minus z*t.
OK, and I think I'll stop there.